[music] the
will of us with a handout of a
packet border does not lend itself to the need to
reinforce its ruins with your good hours of life
and think it’s
like a pasha’s district and either how it is in Russian to
say the
harvest is not in Finnish quandl so
[music] the
lions from the content devices are high  in monte on the
sofa of an individual alexander lukashenko angel the
action
faded us and in odessa in an accident scent of the
ballad
in this life sentence and lose weight
[music]
i protest i want more sleep kind of
soup dig ladoga wallets broth for 26
moves already got cif  novatek who, for
not the vocalist of the
pedals of the eyes, and the lids, my students
were like that, I’m a dan like that at a time, I
went with posters
from a victorious situation and knocked down black and white
verses, well, I won’t walk with a banner
around the city in kale, lada will change
Lukashenka while sitting
[music  ]
after reading is intended jail for this
and my wife svetlana c commission
fixation guys let's Saken steel
standing
obvious two more strong candidates from this
race
threw out then 3 women to  as if they stood up
instead of old men and
that very unification took place that
united all the people of Belarus
with their axons with their networks if the day before the
field is meager chances are
1 second to the right and our struggle
is not pro-Russian not pro-European
there is a struggle within the country against one
person the ultimate goal of all that
Belarus is happening now this is a new honest
absolutely transparent election of everyone don’t
perry imprison everyone don’t kill everyone you won’t
send
evo x mental then to the area of
kenz talzin for is demonstrated in
minsk up to a thousand faces
jamal 6 agency goshenka yes and
kick and w polska
[music]
son ​​selection  was a dentist people 17 l
or both after the battle we don’t throw out the
savannah of the cat’s picket
after the choice if thousands of people in
belarus were shot down
their matta on kirov on the cat’s earth
pony for a human about the departure of the forest
and all this stretches this would actually hair
on  throughout Belarus, where
mass protests took place supra
certification of these elections will be  no movies
top 3 new nissan hubble banton for a
wallet from the design of sokol.ua wild theme
actually people of the levels and fights
of even 26 years old, it can be said that
Belarus was bound inside the tarn by their
fetters
and for a
long hour the saber was not a question of being published,
but that everyone should live  fuss under a meter layer of
dishes but his push did not enter pellets three
words water came to the surface usa
analysis pouring you went nicks caviar
[music]